c'est un environnement toxique où sont
déversés chaque jour 2000 tonnes de
déchets la décharge de tentera et
pourtant aussi une ruche bourdonneante
ou sa paire des centaines de
récupérations informels Brian bisor
India beauty était l'un d'eux jusqu'à ce
qu'il réalise l'ampleur du problème et
l'urgence d'agir
parmi ces déchets on trouve de plus en
plus de vêtements 20 millions de kilos
jetés chaque année ici et qui ont au fil
du temps transformer ce dépotoir en une
montagne de textile
gamin des rues est devenu militant
écologiste du jour au lendemain il mène
aujourd'hui un combat contre les
vêtements
usagers venus de l'Occident source du
problème
[Musique]
paradis des chercheurs d'aubaine et des
croquettes le marché de gui combat et
surtout la Mecque du vêtement usagé
[Musique]
un peu défraîchis venus d'Europe ou
d'Amérique et vendu à petit prix en
Afrique pour y amorcer une deuxième vie
un marché en pleine expansion
partie de rien Rose-Marie rabougui
importe maintenant chaque année 50
conteneurs remplis à Rabat d'habits venu
du Canada
Mambo est un client régulier qui
l'achète aujourd'hui un stock de jeans
impossible de savoir ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur chaque ballot est un paquet
surprise
un business qui vient avec son lot de
risque des vêtements trop usés d'autres
simplement passer de mode
placards que l'on offre à la charité
pour se donner bonne conscience se
retrouve donc bien souvent classé
indésirable ici aussi
la rivière nairobie offre un bien triste
spectacle
une honte selon lui pour un cours d'eau
qui porte le nom de la capitale
de gui combat et juste à côté du
dépotoir selon Brian le problème actuel
est intimement lié au phénomène de la
fast fashion la mode rapide avec des
cycles toujours plus courts et des
vêtements qui ne sont plus faits pour
durer
[Musique]
la consommation mondiale annuelle de
vêtements a plus que doublé au cours des
15 dernières années chaque morceau est
gardé deux fois moins longtemps une
habitude néfaste pour l'environnement
mais qui a aussi beaucoup nuit à
l'industrie kenyane de la mode seul
résiste aujourd'hui des petits créateurs
comme agarer Guy saga qui tente tant
bien que mal de se démarquer pour
survivre
un effet dévastateur sur le plan de la
culture
a choisi de se mettre en mode solution
dans son quartier de Kibera il a fondé
une association écologique les bénévoles
de slums going green parcourent les
allées boueuses du bidonville pour faire
une collecte sélective des déchets
un projet pilote pour valoriser les
déchets textiles
et son groupe sont conscients que le
problème doit surtout se régler à la
source sans glute
aussi lancer le message aux Occidentaux
pour sauver la planète il va falloir
consommer moins consommer mieux
[Musique]